we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this voicemail is a good voicemail aside
from being disgusting
to talk about what we can control and
what we cannot control take a listen to
this put this on your
freaking stupid sideshow you you know
you're nothing but a greasy venezuelan
why don't you go back there and grease
that place up and you sit there
and you throw your hands around you know
what you look like a wounded freaking
chicken
you're an [ __ ] and the biden is gonna
lose and lose
big so screw you you ass
there you go so of course on the facts
i've never been to venezuela i'm
argentinian i am not a fan of the hugo
uh chavez nicholas maduro regime i have
no real
interest um in going to venezuela period
so
that's number one that's just sort of
that xenophobia of listen south america
it's all kind of the same
doesn't really matter etc okay this is
an opportunity to talk about what we can
and we cannot control because the caller
does say
biden's going to lose and he's going to
lose big and i think that
in this moment in time it is a very
uh sort of good opportunity
to understand the teachings of the
stoics i'm talking about
marcus aurelius i'm talking about seneca
i'm talking about i don't know if it's
pronounced epictetus or epictetus
where we need to understand that there
are really three categories
of things in the world they are the
things over we at which we have total
control like for example
i can have total control about my over
my goals i
i decide what are my goals i have
complete control there are things over
which i have
no control like is the sun going to rise
tomorrow i have no control over that
there's no point in worrying about that
and thinking about that
and then there's the area over which we
have some control
the election is one of those cases i can
control
the message i put out on this program i
can control how i vote
i can control whether i make the best
effort possible to convince people that
they should vote and they should vote
for joe biden
but that's as far as my control goes and
you know all of this stuff about
people expecting me to cry on election
night if biden doesn't win
i'm going to be very sad because of what
it means for our country
but i'm going to know i did everything i
could
and then we'll just have to proceed
forward right life will go on
it will be a worse life certainly for
the average person if joe biden doesn't
win
but uh you know all these people with
these personal vendettas they want to
see
me cry on election night uh this is not
about me
this is not about me but i do think it's
a good opportunity for us to understand
where does our sphere of influence end
and as long as we feel that we did
everything we could
that's as far as we really have control
something to keep in mind in advance of
whatever the results are on november 3rd
or whatever day we find out the results
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about
labor day as a possible coronavirus
spike event
we will talk about young americans
living at home with their parents
in greater numbers than we've seen for a
long time since the great depression in
fact
and much more get access to today's
bonus show
and every bonus show by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com